Studio Ghibli has something for everyone,
whether it's a fantastical adventure, drama,
or romance.
In celebration of this vast collection of
animated works, here is a ranking of all of
Ghibli's feature-length films from worst to
best.
Tales from Earthsea follows an exiled prince
and a wandering wizard, as they navigate a
fantasy world.
While some scenes in the film look absolutely
gorgeous, the overall visual quality of the
film lacks consistency.
The film still looks like a Studio Ghibli
film, but it lacks the sense of life that
characterizes other films from the famous
animation studio.
In addition, the plot incorporates elements
from several of the Earthsea books and suffers
as a result.
Tales from Earthsea feels at once bloated
with plot points and characters while also
starved of depth since there's not enough
time to explore each concept.
The sprawling plot and the shallow character
motivations all end up making Tales from Earthsea
the weakest Studio Ghibli film by far.
My Neighbors the Yamadas is a comedy in the
style of a Japanese comic strip.
The film is a compilation of stories following
members of the Yamada family.
In each segment, different issues are explored,
like disputes between the married couple and
the various relationships of the family members.
Though My Neighbors the Yamadas is an inoffensive
and entertaining watch, the film simply pales
in comparison to other Studio Ghibli titles.
It's definitely not the most impressive entry
in the studio's long history, but My Neighbors
the Yamadas is a cute film with comedic elements
that many viewers are bound to enjoy.
From Up on Poppy Hill follows Umi Matsuzaki,
a high school student in the port city of
Yokohama.
Each morning outside of the boarding house
where she lives, Umi raises a series of signal
flags in honor of her father, who died during
the Korean War.
One day, she meets a boy who wrote about her
flags in his student newspaper, and the two
set about renovating the building where the
school clubs are supposed to be held.
The pair begin to fall for each other as they
continue working on the renovation, even after
the school board decides to demolish the building.
The setting is perhaps where the film shines
the brightest.
While the city of Yokohama isn't a fantastical
setting for a film, the film nearly makes
it seem fantastical by paying special attention
to the time period.
The story takes place in 1963 as the nation
gets ready to host the 1964 Olympic Games,
and the little touches throughout the film
help to ground the story in a specific time
and place.
From Up on Poppy Hill isn't a bad film overall,
but the film's mundane setting and somewhat
predictable plot weaken the experience.
"It's not a young kid story, it's not a magical
story like Ponyo, but there's a beauty to
it because it's animated."
Porco Rosso follows a former Italian fighter
pilot who is cursed to look like an anthropomorphic
pig.
After the First World War, Porco makes it
his duty to hunt down air-pirates who use
their planes to wreak havoc on honest people.
But when a young pirate shoots his aircraft
down, Porco has to make a dangerous journey
to his mechanic so he can repair his plane.
Porco Rosso is a lighthearted action film
that goes to great lengths to show Hayao Miyazaki's
admiration of early aviation.
There are a lot of shots of Porco operating
his plane with the use of several levers,
sticks, and pedals that highlights the film's
attention to detail.
While the story is relatively safe, the real
draw of this film is the action during the
mid-air dogfights.
Though not as groundbreaking as other Studio
Ghibli titles, Porco Rosso still has plenty
to offer as a film.
The Wind Rises is a fictionalized biography
of Jiro Horikoshi, a renowned Japanese airplane
designer from the early 20th century.
The film follows Jiro as he falls in love
with his terminally ill wife, and finds fulfillment
in designing planes.
However, throughout the film, Jiro worries
about the ethics surrounding his invention,
since he primarily develops them for the Japanese
military.
The Wind Rises centers on a prominent historical
figure who many Americans have likely never
heard of.
While that could have been interesting on
its own, the film unfortunately suffers from
pacing problems that make The Wind Rises feel
dragged out.
Still, for history buffs and fans of aviation,
The Wind Rises is likely to soar to the top
of your favorite movie lists.
"Airplanes are beautiful dreams, engineered
to turn dreams into reality."
"Yes."
"Arrividerci!"
In Pom Poko, construction on the outskirts
of Tokyo has led to the surrounding forest
becoming drained of its natural resources.
As the threat of deforestation looms, magical
creatures known as tanuki take desperate measures.
They begin staging elaborate hauntings to
scare humans, attracting media attention,
and even relying on eco-terrorism to stall
construction.
Pom Poko is an environmentally conscious film
that aims to highlight the plight of animals
rapidly losing their lands to suburban development.
Despite some heavy-handed themes and awkward
pacing, the film has plenty of fun, expressive
animation that still makes Pom Poko an engaging
watch.
Similar to The Little Mermaid, Ponyo is a
cute love story about a fish-girl named Ponyo
who befriends Sosuke, a human boy, when she
strays away from home.
Ponyo is a genuinely beautiful film with amazingly
creative designs, both in terms of world-building
and characters.
However, it suffers from slow pacing and an
overly simple story.
That being said, Ponyo isn't aiming for depth;
the film wants to take viewers on a fantastical
visual journey under the sea, and in that
respect, it excels.
Though it isn't perfect, Ponyo is more than
worth watching for the gorgeous animation
and cute childish romance between Sosuke and
Ponyo.
After Haru Yoshioka saves the life of a cat
crossing the street, her life takes a turn
for the weird when the cat turns out to be
the prince of Cat Kingdom and asks for her
hand in marriage.
With a fantastical premise, The Cat Returns
is a cute fantasy adventure that's plenty
of fun to watch.
Still, the film lacks the grand scope that
has come to be expected from Studio Ghibli
titles.
Compared to the visual masterpiece of Spirited
Away, which was released during the same year
as The Cat Returns, the latter film is both
lighter in tone and bit less daring in terms
of animation.
Still, the film is definitely enjoyable on
its own merits, and is an overall solid flick
for animation fans and cat lovers alike.
"Hi, Charlie Kelly here, local business owner
and cat enthusiast!"
When Marnie Was There follows Anna, a young
girl sent to live with her foster parents'
family in Hokkaido due to her poor health.
Anna is lonely and depressed until she meets
a strangely familiar girl named Marnie, a
mysterious blond girl living in a dilapidated
old house in the marshes.
The true strength of When Marnie Was There
lies largely in its interesting female leads.
Anna has trouble connecting with others and
considers herself an outlier in her society.
Given this, the relationship that develops
between Anna and Marnie is incredibly sincere
as it develops throughout, giving Anna someone
that she can finally relate to.
In the end, the great connection shared by
the two leads, the mystery surrounding Marnie's
character, and the film's impressive animation
all come together to create a satisfying and
relatable film.
"In my dreams, I saw a girl just like you."
"Dreams.
Hmm."
Howl's Moving Castle follows Sophie, a hatmaker
who is cursed to look like an old woman by
a witch.
While traveling to find a way to break the
witch's spell, Sophie meets an enchanted scarecrow
and seeks out Howl, a wizard who lives in
a magical moving castle.
Miyazaki's works are always filled with commentaries
on how humans interact with nature, staying
true to the creator's passion for taking care
of the environment.
However, Howl's Moving Castle also focuses
around how humans interact and bond with each
other.
In conveying this theme, Howl's Moving Castle
considers complicated topics such as war,
loyalty to nations, and coming to terms with
aging.
The unique variety of themes combines with
the now-standard fare of breathtaking animation,
fun characters, and plenty of humor.
All together, it makes Howl's Moving Castle
one of the most inventive Studio Ghibli films
around.
The princess of the Valley of the Wind is
Nausicaä, an adventurous young woman who
wants her people to coexist with the neighboring
Toxic Jungle and its animal and insect inhabitants.
However, the peace of the Valley is put at
risk when a plane from a neighboring country
crashes in the Valley.
The plane's cargo harbors the embryo of a
Giant Warrior, an enormous and dangerous insect
that will be used to destroy the Toxic Jungle.
Everything falls to Nausicaä to find a way
to restore peace to both lands and find harmony
between nature and humans.
Nausicaä of the Valley of the Wind is one
of Hayao Miyazaki's most environmentally conscious
features, and one that's clearly close to
his heart.
The film was created before Studio Ghibli's
existence, but the success of Nausicaä is
what led to the studio's creation.
Without Nausicaä, it is fair to assume we
may not have gotten many of the Studio Ghibli
titles that we have today.
Even beyond its place in the Studio's history,
Nausicaa is breathtakingly original, with
all of the unique character designs and luscious
animation that you would expect.
In Whisper of the Heart, Shizuki is a student
about to take her high school entrance exams.
She soon meets Seiji, a talented musician
who dreams of becoming a master violin maker.
Seiji leaves for Italy to follow his dreams,
while Shizuki decides to devote herself to
writing.
While other Studio Ghibli films may stand
out for their lush environments or their tense
action scenes, Whisper of the Heart's strength
is the emotional journey that the Shizuki
goes on throughout the film.
Whisper of the Heart is impressive in how
it tackles the creative process and the struggles
of balancing creative endeavors with more
traditional pursuits.
The film is relatable and down to earth, making
Whisper of the Heart one of the more uniquely
mundane films from the studio.
Initially released in 1993, Ocean Waves is
a bit different from other Studio Ghibli titles
in that it was originally produced for television.
Additionally, it's the first Ghibli film not
to feature Hayao Miyazaki or Isao Takahata
as director.
Ocean Waves tells the story of a love triangle
between Taku, his best friend Yutaka, and
the new exchange student Rikaku.
After Taku joins Rikaku for an unexpected
trip to Tokyo, tensions rise, and rumors begin
to develop about Rikaku and Taku's relationship.
As a result, Rikaku, Taku, and Yutaka must
confront the change in dynamics and the nature
of their relationships with one another.
For a teenage love story, the overall likable
Ocean Waves is generally pretty good.
Though it may not be as strong as similar
Studio Ghibli films, it's a solid, engaging
drama.
After moving closer to their hospital-bound
mother, sisters Satsuki and Mei discover a
host of magical beings living in their new
town.
Guided by friendly dust creatures, Mei meets
Totoro, a giant cat-like animal that lives
in a hollow by the girl's house.
Eventually, Totoro also reveals himself to
Satsuki, and the sisters are introduced to
the whimsical life shared by Totoro and his
fantastical friends.
Though the film is mostly filled with cute
critters and upbeat interactions between Satsuki
and her younger sister, it also has its fair
share of tension.
My Neighbor Totoro is wildly fun to watch,
and instills a sense of childlike wonder that
few other films can achieve.
Considering Castle in the Sky was the first
film to be produced under the name Studio
Ghibli in 1986, it stands the test of time
incredibly well.
The story begins with Sheeta, a young orphan
pursued by space pirates and government officials
for her mysterious necklace.
Sheeta is found and sheltered by another orphan
named Pazu.
The two go on a journey to uncover the secrets
of Sheeta's necklace and its airborne origin.
Castle in the Sky does a good job of setting
the tone for future Studio Ghibli films in
that it has a sweeping soundtrack, a mystical
world filled with advanced technology, and
themes surrounding humans and their relationship
to nature.
While better Ghibli films would come later,
Castle in the Sky remains a standout in the
studio's history.
The Secret World of Arrietty film follows
a family of borrowers, tiny people who scavenge
or borrow from the houses of ordinary humans.
The family's safety is threatened when the
young boy of the house, Sho, sees Arrietty
while she and her father are borrowing in
his room late one night.
While Studio Ghibli films are renowned for
their ability to create fantastical worlds,
The Secret World of Arrietty engenders that
same sense of wonder, scope, and adventure
within its utterly normal setting.
In addition to beautiful animation and excellent
art design, the film has a lovely soundtrack
that helps build on the sweet overall tone.
With a blend of fantastic music and visuals,
The Secret World of Arrietty is a beautiful
tale of blossoming friendship that perfectly
balances between a calm, slice-of-life narrative
and a fun adventure story.
"I am very proud of you.
A lesser borrower would have panicked and
run away."
In Princess Mononoke, Prince Ashitaka finds
himself poisoned after a demon attacks his
village.
In search of a cure, Ashitaka goes to Iron
Town, where the people cut down the forest
to fuel their manufacturing-based society.
This disturbance of nature upsets the spirits
of the forest, who go to war with the people
of Iron Town.
As the war threatens to wipe out both the
nature spirits and the humans, Ashitaka and
San, a human raised by spirits, must work
together to achieve some form of peace.
One of Ghibli's most well-known pictures,
Princess Mononoke does an excellent job of
blending an action-packed adventure with a
nuanced environmental message.
Kiki's Delivery Service follows a young witch
named Kiki as she leaves her home and begins
her training as a witch in a new town.
Supported by her talking black cat Jiji, she
flies to a seaside town where she's hosted
by a friendly baker and her husband.
Quickly, Kiki finds her footing as a delivery
girl and captures the attention of a boy named
Tombo, who clamors for her attention.
Kiki's Delivery Service is a magical tale
with beautiful animation that makes the film's
world feel warm and idyllic.
All of the characters are expressive and relatable,
especially Kiki, who struggles to fit into
her new town and discover her unique talents.
Starting as over-confident and slowly becoming
isolated and unsure, Kiki is a brilliantly
fleshed-out character that encourages viewers
to overcome obstacles and fly high.
Only Yesterday strays away from Studio Ghibli
conventions by targeting older viewers as
opposed to teens and children.
The film explores the life of Taeko Okajima,
an unmarried woman who takes a trip outside
of Tokyo to the rural countryside.
Outside the city, Taeko begins to feel nostalgia
for her childhood and questions her life choices.
Because of Only Yesterday's focus on an adult
protagonist and her growing disillusionment
with her life, the film offers a mature and
reflective exploration of aging.
Unlike many other Ghibli titles, there's no
magical adventures.
Instead, the story of Only Yesterday offers
a slice of life experience that is grounded
in reality.
The film does an excellent job of fleshing
out Taeko's memories and allows her to come
to terms with who she is and what she wants
out of life.
Only Yesterday has a unique charm and relays
a beautiful story of growth, reflection, and
self-discovery.
"This scenery has come about by accident as
people have struggled to get what they needed
to survive."
With a distinct watercolor aesthetic, The
Tale of the Princess Kaguya is a beautifully
animated movie based on a beloved Japanese
folk tale.
In the film, a bamboo cutter finds a girl
inside a bamboo shoot, whom he names Kaguya.
Realizing that the girl is divine, he moves
Kaguya to a mansion in the capital where she
is trained to become a noble lady, despite
Kaguya's growing discomfort.
The Tale of the Princess Kaguya is without
a doubt one of Studio Ghibli's most visually
unique works.
With distinct animation and style, the film
is an incredible experience from start to
finish.
Arguably the most well-known of the Studio
Ghibli films, Spirited Away follows Chihiro
as she works to save her parents, who unknowingly
trespassed into the world of spirits.
As punishment for stealing food, Chihiro's
parents are transformed into pigs by the powerful
witch Yubaba.
While working at a bathhouse to save her family,
Chihiro learns determination, how to assert
herself, and the value of compassion.
Spirited Away is absolutely gorgeous, with
masterful animation and heartfelt character
designs.
The fantastic visuals, accompanied by the
film's colorful cast of creative, lovable
characters, solidifies Spirited Away as one
of the most beloved animated films of all
time.
Taking place in Japan during World War II,
Grave of the Fireflies follows Seita and Setsuko,
siblings who manage to survive a firebombing
that destroys their home.
Thrust into the role of a parent, Seita must
find a way to feed himself and his sister
in the midst of rapidly shrinking supplies.
Grave of the Fireflies is unique in that it
reveals the main character's deaths at the
beginning of the film.
The remainder of the runtime is told through
a flashback that contextualizes Seita's death
and the hardships he was forced to endure.
Ultimately, the film is a grim and heartbreaking
experience that bears far more weight than
any other Studio Ghibli movie.
In the end, Seita and Setsuko are innocent
children whose lives are destroyed by a war
they had no say in.
In a post-war society, no one can provide
for these children, forcing Seita into an
adult role he is largely unprepared to handle.
While Grave of the Fireflies may prove too
difficult for some viewers to endure, the
film's message about war and tragedy is powerful.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.